donc je vais vous parler d'une comédie
pas très connue et pourtant avec de
grands acteurs et un grand scénariste un
grand réalisateur c'est le film tais-toi
qui est sorti en 2003
donc de Francis vper donc grand nombre
du cinéma français
on parle on peut parler de d'un film de
détente familiale vraiment un film
humoristique avec un enchaînement de
gags
mais à en rire et en pleurer on est sur
de la recherche de fraternité absolue de
camaraderie entre ces deux acteurs qui
sont tout simplement Jean Reno et Gérard
Depardieu
Jean Reno est un
braqueur de braqueurs
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire il
braque des braqueurs et nous avons donc
Gérard Depardieu appelé Quentin de
Montargis un con absolu et débile sur
beaucoup de bord
qui est également braqueur mais
braqueurs de de bureau de change on va
dire ça comme ça ils se retrouvent en
fait tous les deux un jour dans une
cellule genre Hainaut
sauf que en fait il ne savait pas que un
véritable qu'on pouvait exister comme ça
nous avons d'ailleurs à ce moment-là
d'autres acteurs comme André du soulier
qui est fabuleux dans dans le rôle du
médecin et juste pour vous dire une
petite histoire André Dussollier sort
c'est pas un indice de fou qu'il
faudrait pour eux mais ça serait un
asile de cons mais vous imaginez la
taille de bâtiment du coup Jean Reno lui
veut se venger de la mort de sa femme
tout en cachant le butin qu'il a volé au
méchant et en fait ils vont devoir faire
main dans la main pour avancer dans
cette histoire sauf qu'on est confronté
à un Auguste un clown blanc et nous
partons sur des émotions des dialogues
forts un film donc hilarant on peut
parler de
tandem réussie avec un Depardieu en
apogée